Hey guys, Pete here. this is my watchman
season 1 episode 2 recap and review the
episode is titled "Martial Feats of
Comanche Horsemanship"which is the name
of a painting we see later in chief
Crawford's house. It was directed by Nicole
Kassell who helmed the pilot episode as
well and written by Damon Lindelof and
Nick Cuse. it asks a lot more questions than
it answers which is alright by me at
this point. the recap portion will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in the Watchmen universe
through episode 2 of the HBO series
after that I'll dig into speculation
about where things might be headed I'll
talk about trailers and different things
that we've seen so consider yourself
warned.
the episode opens with a series of
flashbacks. we see the German propaganda
pamphlet that Will Reeves ends up
holding under chief Crawford's hanging
body and how it came to be there. if you
missed this Easter egg from episode one
it's a real pamphlet that the Germans
dropped to lower the morale of troops
during World War I and it was the
piece of paper that Will's father wrote
the watch over this boy note on before
getting him out of the massacre in Tulsa.
here with a nifty shift of narration
from character to character we see it
travel from real history into the
alternate reality that is Watchmen. the
importance of the paper itself isn't
exactly clear but Will is essentially
verified to be the young boy we saw from
the opening of the series. we learned
that Angela took him away from the scene
of the hanging rather than calling it in
it's a strange move considering the
situation and I guess we're supposed to
interpret it as her not knowing what to
think and wanting to investigate without
distraction. she brings him to her bakery
and after letting her emotion show
briefly in the back room she dons her
costume before she asks him any
questions. the exchange here is a good
one. I particularly liked how they
debated what Dr. Manhattan could or
couldn't do as Will mentions things
directly shown in the comic book panels.
this is echoed again later between Cal
and Angela and I thought that that was a
lot of fun for those of us who read the
original story. he tells of the vast and
insidious conspiracy at play and that
Crawford has skeletons in his closet.
Angela takes this literally and she bags
up his coffee cup for the DNA evidence
before heading to the crime scene. there's
this easter egg filled transition of a
newsstand as she leaves. we see a mural
on the wall of two lovers kissing, a shot
of the new frontiersman, a mention of the
Nova Express which was owned by Veidt
enterprises, and we hear of the Libstappo running false flags to keep everyone
distracted while they take away people's
rights. the newsstand is a callback to
the comics complete with this new
character, who I recognized as Bunny from
the Wire but he's been in a ton of things,
we see that he's wearing the same type a
hat as his comic counterpart another new
character arrives to pick up some papers
for a mystery woman based on their
conversation if you've been watching the
trailers or anything really it's obvious
who this character is connected to but
I'll leave it as a mystery if you're
trying to remain spoiler free. at the
crime scene Angela gets filled in on
some of the details from Looking Glass.
he's very matter-of-fact in his
description and that stands out and we
learned that Judd did indeed suffer as
his life came to an end. the conversation
is cut short by a paparazzi falling from
the sky the guys wearing a moth setup
which is pretty hilarious. Red Scare is
present the underline the idea that
tensions are running high and the police
force won't be taking kindly to the
murder of their boss. I found all of this
intriguing and we get a couple of
emotional moments where Angela says that
Looking Glass is a cold motherfucker
only for him to reveal that he's crying
under his mask and Angela embracing the
body of her friend as they cut him down
from the tree. that transitions us to
another flashback where we see the
events of the White Night unfold at the
Abar house on Christmas the 7th Kavalry
burst in shot guns blazing. Angela is
able to stab her first attacker only to
pass out after being shot as the second
gunman hovers over her. she wakes up
three days later in the hospital with
then captain Judd sitting by her
bedside. he fills her in on the details
of what happened including the fact that
her partner was killed. we understand
that this is where her adopted children
come from and we see how Judd and Angela
formed their friendship and this bond
starts between them. Red Scare lays out
the plan to head over to Nixonville to
beat some answers out of its inhabitants
and that's exactly what the police do. Angela
thinks that maybe they should stop and
think, she's even reluctant to join in
until one of them takes a swing at her
with the bat and then she unloads on him
mercilessly which lets us know that
she's dealing with this but also that
she's a very capable fighter. after that
she takes the coffee mug over to the
Greenwood Center for cultural heritage
and this is so she can test for Will's
DNA. it was a little bit hokey I thought
the way that this was set up but the
signs of the protesters outside almost
make up for it. they read you got a sorry
and now you want a handout and equal
rights equals equal taxes. I mean this is
the kind of thing I would imagine would
be going on outside of a place like this
if it really existed in our world. back
at her place a lot of stuff happens in a
short amount of time we see the adopted
kids grandfather sitting on the porch.
apparently he's there for a visit that
isn't happening. he complains about Redfordations a bit before taking a hand
out from her to go away. Cal asks about
the old man who's still at the bakery.
he's wondering why Angelo didn't arrest
him which we're kind of wondering the
same thing.
she tells Topher about uncle Judd's death
with the monologue we've heard in a
couple of trailers at this point about
the world being black and white.
speaking of monologues American Crime
Story Minutemen makes its debut and
everyone seems to be watching it. Cal and
Topher, Looking Glass is at his place with
the TV dinner sitting down to watch it,
and the 7th Kalvary who are hard at work
at a suicide vest are also tuning in.
this has been highly anticipated and it
doesn't disappoint.
after a comically long-winded advisory
we learned some important information.
the show inside the show opens with the
body of Rolf Mueller being discovered in
Boston Harbor in 1955. this was who
Hollis Mason speculated that Hooded
Justice might be in this book Under the
Hood turns out that isn't the case if we
believe this TV show which if you
haven't read the source material this is
all probably getting pretty confusing. to
say it as simply as it can be the
implication here is that everything
people think they know about the rise of
costume adventuring and the Watchmen
universe could be wrong. it's an
interesting thing to tuck in the back of
our minds at this point as is the long
monologue that Hooded Justice gives
about his backstory and wearing masks
in the show itself. we hear that continue
as Angela drives over to the Crawford
house and it seems to fit with her sense
of identity as well. at the Chief's place
after meeting Senator Keene she pretends
to faint so that she can get access to
the upstairs and the Chief's closet. she
ends up finding a Klan robe with a
sheriff's badge hidden there with the
help of some nite owl looking x-ray
specs. this twist isn't terribly
surprising after the first episode but
this thing is just hanging there like a
display in a museum which was sort of
like okay, what? either way though Angela
grabs it and takes off. she takes it with
her we transition from a shot of the
painting that the episode gets its name
from over to the English manor. things
are still weird here and I find it
delightful.
where it is and why things are the way
they are isn't any clearer than it was
in the pilot but the fact that his
servants are clones seems to be
confirmed. we watched the play about the
creation of Dr. Manhattan which is put
together really well for the
circumstances and we're left to wonder
what this will all turn out to mean. back
at the bakery Angela finds that Will has
escaped the handcuffs, he went across the
street to the grocery store, and now he's
there cooking some eggs.
oh yeah he's also her grandfather which
she finds out and he's there to show her
where she came from.
she suspects that he has something to do
with the robe that she found because
it's difficult to think of her friend
being a closeted Klansmen. he believably
says that he doesn't know what she's
talking about. he didn't mean literally
that he had skeletons in his closet but
she decides to arrest him. when she takes
him outside to load him into the car and
an airship swoops in to rescue him. as
the cars taken away be a giant magnet
the pamphlet from the beginning of the
episode drops from the sky he makes a
clean getaway and she's left there
wondering just like we are what the hell
just happened. the episode ends there
with an outro of the Beastie Boys Eggman
which is a fantastic way to end as far
as I'm concerned. the Klan robe
seems like a big reveal in the sense
that it confirms there's more to
Crawford's character. more than anything
it makes you wonder if he has a
connection to the seventh Cavalry. he was
shot during the white night though, we
saw that there was dressing on his
wounds at the hospital and he had
noticeable gunshot scars when we saw him
getting dressed in the first episode. at
the same time he was listening to
right-wing
radio and he has clear ties to the clan
even if he wasn't a member himself. the
fact that Angela survived the White
Night is also weird considering that
she passed out with an armed 7k guy
standing over her. there's definitely
more going on here than what we've seen
but at this point it's hard to pin down
what that is. then we have Will who we
learned a lot about in some ways but
maybe not the things that we were hoping
to find out. a lot of people like the
theory that he could be hooded justice
and it does seem a little bit more
likely after this episode. I like the
idea where maybe he was the inspiration
for Hooded justice or that there was
more than one of them or something along
those lines but but either way American
hero story revealing that Hooded
Justice wasn't Rolf Mueller could be
big. I'm guessing that Will was saved at
the end by LadyTrieus people but that's
not exactly a slam dunk.
I think some people will wonder if maybe
Nite Owl II was involved in this but that
seems pretty far-fetched. the question of
whether he killed the chief or not is
still out there and if he did then why?
him being Angela's grandfather could be
important but we also know that she grew
up in Vietnam where something probably
happened to her parents. so does any of
what we saw today move us closer to
solving the mystery that he represents? I
don't think so.
and of course the same goes for the old
lord of the manor.
he seems trapped or imprisoned or
something. he's got quite a few clones at
his disposal and he really enjoys the
play that he authored about Dr.
Manhattan. fans are probably thrilled
that they got a blue dong finally here
in this episode but I'm not sure it
explains much about what's going on
there in that part of the world. and, I'm
not complaining I like building out the
stories of the characters and like
having the mystery stew simmering over
there on the stovetop. the Easter eggs
are everywhere and yet they don't seem
obnoxious in a way that they're being
presented. there's a ton of good theories
popping up that you can ponder and I'm
not sure I'm married to any of them yet.
it's a good place to be. review wise I
think this is a good follow up to a
solid pilot episode. in my mind it could
be difficult to transition from that and
I think they did a really good job. the
world-building is still really
impressive, the directing again was
really fantastic in this episode,
there were a couple of scenes that were
goofy like I mentioned the DNA test and
when she first discovered the Klan robe,
but I liked how they sort of looped back
on those and they pointed out sort of
how like 1) it was crazy that Angela
took him literally in that there being
something in his closet and 2) how easy
she found it and so on you get the idea.
I think it's really cool how they
sort of loop back on that whenever her
and Cal were talking. visually
everything looked consistent and good.
it's hard to find things to complain
about here. The music, the actors performances,
the look of everything, it seems to be
firing on all cylinders. as far as
speculation for what's to come
Laurie Blake should arrive in the next
episode based on the trailers and I've got
to wonder if Angela taking Will away from
the crime scene is gonna come back to
bite her. him leaving the way he did
makes me wonder if we're gonna see him
at all for a couple of episodes. since
not much time has passed we should be
getting the funeral with some backstory
on Laurie and a better idea of what the
Kalvary are planning. My thought about
that is that they're probably using
those batteries they're gonna stage
something that will prove that the
batteries themselves aren't dangerous,
that it was all hysteria. from the Petey
Files we learned that there was a big
backlash against Dr. Manhattan related
technologies after the squid attack
which is why the batteries aren't used
anymore. the Kalvary rightly believed
that the attack was staged by Ozymandias
so I think undermining the idea that the
batteries are toxic would go
hand-in-hand with the attack being a
hoax. on top of that I think will learn
about Lady Trieu
the mysterious Vietnamese trillionaire
who has taken over most of what was left
of Veidt industries. we'll learn about
what her plan to save the world is all
about which means that we have a lot to
look forward. to let me know what you
guys think in the comments and let me
know what kind of bonus watchmen videos
you might want to see what series do you
have which ones that are out there do
you like where is this thing going
what's going on with Ozymandias what's
going on with wil is he hooded justice
or is it something else
make sure you like this video if you
enjoyed it make sure you subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
that's it for today thanks for watching
I will talk to you soon